نبقى مع الشان الايراني فقط تحصل موقعه
ايران انترناشونال على رسائل سريه من
وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه تظهر تشددا من
البنك التجاري العراقي فيما يتعلق بسحب
الاموال الايرانيه المحجوبه ووفقا لتلك
الرسائل السريه فان المصرف التجاري
العراقي ليس على استعدادا لتنفيذ معاملات
بالمليارات يطلبها الجانب الايراني وانه
على استعداد فقط للافراج عن موارد ايران
في الحالات الانسانيه وبكميات قليله
وبقيود مشدده ايضا وباشراف كامل من وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه رئيس البنك التجاري
العراقي بلال الحمداني اشار بحسب ايران
انترناشونال الى ان عقبه التصاريح
الامريكيه في هذا المجال قائلا انه ليس
فقط من الضروري الحصول على تصريح من وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه لدفع ثمن المواد
الانسانيه وانما يجب الحصول على تصريح
لبنود اخرى وانه يتعين على ايران ارسال
مشاهدات ووثائق تحدد البضائع الانسانيه
التي تم شرائها وبخصوص طلب ايران نقل اصول
بقيمه مليون دولار لشركه مبنى مختصه بمجال
الطاقه اكد رئيس البنك التجاري العراقي
انه بسبب المعاملات المشبوهه فقد صدر
تعميم ضد شركه مبنى ولا يمكن تلبيه طلب
الجانب الايراني في هذا الصدد ويتساءل
البنك التجاري العراقي عن البنك الذي
ستودع فيه المبالغ باعتبار ان البنك
المركزي الايراني تحت عقوبات من قبل
الولايات المتحده وكشفت تجار العراقي ايضا
عن عدم وجود تخطيط او تنسيق في حكومه
ابراهيم رئيسي لتوفير العمله للسلع
الاساسيه من الاموال الايرانيه المحجوبه
في العراق